what i hope to do in this video is get
familiar with the notion of an interval
and also think about ways that we can
show an interval or interval notation so
right over here i have a number line now
let's say i wanted to talk about the
interval on the number line that goes
from let's say from negative 3
to 2. so i care about this let me just a
different color
let's say i care about this interval
right over here so i care about all of
the numbers from negative 3
negative 3 to 2.
so in order to be more precise i have to
be clear am i including negative 3 and 2
or am i not including negative 3 and 2
or maybe i'm just including one of them
so if i'm including negative 3 and 2
then i would fill them in
so this right over here i'm filling
negative 3 and 2 in which means that
negative 3 and 2 are part of this
interval and when you include the end
points this is called a closed interval
closed interval
closed interval and i just showed you
how i can depict it on a number line by
actually filling in
filling in the endpoints
and there's multiple ways to talk about
this interval mathematically i could say
that this is all of the let's say that
this is
let's say this number line is showing
different values for x i could say these
are all of the x's
that are between negative 3
negative 3
and 2
and 2. and notice that negative 3 is
less than or equal to x so that's
telling us that x could be equal to that
x could be equal to negative 3 and then
we have x is less than or equal to
positive 2 so that means that x could be
equal to positive 2. so it is a closed
interval
now another way that we could depict
this closed interval is we could say
okay we're talking about the interval
between and we could use brackets
because it's a closed interval
negative 3
and 2. and once again i'm using brackets
here these brackets tell us that we
include so this bracket on the left say
that we include a negative 3 and this
bracket on the right says that we
include positive 2 in our interval now
sometimes you might see things written a
little bit more mathy you might see
something like that like x is a member
of the real numbers such that
so and i could put these curly brackets
around like this these curly brackets
say that we're talking about a set of
values and we're seeing the set of all
x's that are a member of the real
numbers so this is just fancy math
notation it's a member of the real
numbers i'm using the greek letter
epsilon right over here to say member of
the real numbers such that this little
this this vertical line here means such
that negative 3 is less than x is less
than or negative 3 is less than or equal
to x is less than or equal to 2.
i could also write it this way i could
write x
is a member of the real numbers such
that x is a member such that x is a
member of this closed set i'm including
i including the end points here so these
are all different ways of of denoting or
depicting the same interval let's do
some more examples here so let's let me
draw a number line again
so
number line
and now let me do well let me just do an
open interval
an open interval just so that we see
we clearly can see the difference so
let's say that i want to talk about the
values between negative 1 and 4
negative let me do some different color
so the value is between negative 1
and 4
but i don't want to include negative 1
and 4.
so this is going to be an open interval
so i'm not going to include 4 and i'm
not going to include and i'm not going
to include negative 1. notice i have
open circles here over here i had closed
circles the closed circles told me that
i included negative 3 and 2. now i have
open circles here so that says that i'm
not it's all the values in between
negative 1 and 4. so negative 1 or
negative 0.999999 is going to be
included but negative 1 is not going to
be included and
3.99999999 is going to be included but 4
is not going to be included
so how would we what what would be the
notation for this well here we could say
x is going to be a member of the real
numbers such that
negative 1 i'm not going to say less
than or equal to because x isn't x can't
be equal to negative 1. so negative 1 is
strictly less than x
is strictly less than 4. notice not less
than or equal because i can't be equal
to 4 4 is not included so that's one way
to say it or another way i could write
it like this
x is a member of the real numbers
such that x is a member of
now the interval is from negative 1
to 4 but i'm not going to use these
brackets these brackets say hey let me
include the endpoints but i'm not going
to include them so i'm going to put the
parentheses right over here the
parentheses so this tells us that we're
dealing with an open interval so this
right over here let me make it clear
this is
an open
and open interval now you're probably
wondering okay in this in this case both
endpoints were included it's a closed
interval in this case both at endpoints
were excluded it's an open interval can
you have things that have one endpoint
included and one endpoint excluded and
the answer is absolutely let's see an
example of that
so i'll get another number line here
another
another number line
and let's say that we want to
actually let me do it the other way
around let me write it first and then
i'll i'll graph it so let's say we're
thinking about all of the x's that are a
member of the real numbers such that
let's say
negative 4 let's say negative 4 is not
included is less than x
is less than or equal to negative 1. so
now negative 1 is included so we're not
going to include negative 4 negative 4
is strictly less than not less than or
equal to so x can't be equal to negative
4 so open circle there but x could be
equal to negative 1 has to be less than
or equal to negative 1.
so it could be equal to negative 1 so
i'm going to fill that in right over
there and then it's everything in
between
if i want to write it with this notation
i could write
x is a member of the real numbers such
that x
is a member of the interval
so it's going to go between negative 4
and negative 1 but we're not including
negative 4. we have an open circle here
so i'm going to put a parenthesis on
that side but we are including we are
including negative one
we are including negative one
so we put a bracket on that side
and so that would be
that right over there would be the
notation
now there's other things that you could
do with interval notation you could say
well hey everything except for some
value so let me give another example of
let me let's get another
example here let's let's say that we we
want to talk about all the real numbers
except for one
so we want to include
so we want to include all of the real
numbers
all of the real numbers
except
except for one
except for one so we're going to exclude
one right over here so open circle but
it can be any other
any other real number
so how would we how would we how would
we denote this
well we could write we could right
x is a member of the real numbers
such that
x
does not equal
does not equal 1.
so here i'm saying look x can be a
member of the real numbers but x cannot
be equal to one it can be anything else
but it cannot be equal to one and
there's other ways of denoting this
exact same interval you could say
you could say x is a member of the real
numbers
such that x is you could say such that x
is less than
one
or
x is greater than one
so you could you could write it just
like that or you could do something
interesting all right this is probably
this is the one that i would use this is
the shortest and it makes it very clear
saying hey everything except for one but
you can even do something fancy like you
could say x is a member of the real
numbers such that x is a member of the
set
going from negative infinity
to 1 not including 1
or
x is a member of the set going from or a
member of the interval going from 1 not
including 1 all the way to positive all
the way to positive infinity and when
you're talking about
negative infinity or positive infinity
you always put up you always put a
parenthesis and the view there is you
can never include everything all the way
up to infinity it's it's it needs to be
at least open at that end point because
infinity just keeps going on and on so
you always want to put a parenthesis if
you're talking about infinity or
negative infinity it's not really an end
point it keeps going on and on forever
so you use the notation for open
interval at least at that at that end
and notice we're not including we're not
including one either so if x is a member
of of this interval or that interval it
essentially can be anything other than
one but this would have been the
simplest notation to to describe that